en todas las charlas del déficit en el
que estamos entrando del proyecto de ley
del estímulo económico de todo el dinero
que se gasta en el rescate de los bancos
y potencialmente también de la industria
automotriz la pregunta que todos tienen
es esto conducirá a inflación y esto es
lo que espero discutir en este vídeo un
buen lugar donde empezar es bueno pues
qué es la inflación y es un incremento
general en los precios de bienes y
servicios y esto se mide por bueno tomar
una cesta de bienes y servicios y miran
como esos precios se comparan con un año
de referencia si los precios suben un 3%
ellos pueden usar un índice de precios
del consumidor dirían que la inflación
incrementó un 3% y eso es lo que es la
inflación lo opuesto de la inflación
sería si los bienes se reducen eso sería
la deflación si en un año 10 megabytes
de rne cuestan x dólares y al año
siguiente cuestan un poco menos entonces
es es de hecho un proceso deflacionario
por lo menos en ese mercado entonces con
esas definiciones listas hablemos un
poco sobre las causas
hace un par de días yo hice unos vídeos
sobre la economía de los pastelillos de
los cupcakes donde bueno teníamos
fábricas de pastelillos y que tenían una
alta o baja utilización que podía
ocurrir con los precios la razón por la
que hice eso es porque quiero dejar
claro que realmente la utilización de
las fábricas o el personal es lo que
conduce los precios
ahora digamos que esta es toda la
capacidad que yo tengo y cuando hablo de
capacidad en este vídeo me refiero en
términos generales que son todos los
bienes y servicios que podemos producir
podríamos hablar solo de capacidad
laboral y entonces la tasa de desempleo
es una medida de lo que no está siendo
utilizado pero esto solo es digamos
nuestra capacidad productiva total y en
esos vídeos de economía mostré que si la
demanda empuja en contra de la capacidad
permítanme cambiar el color de la
demanda si la demanda está realmente
cerca de la de la capacidad digamos esto
lo voy a hacer con dibujos entonces en
en esta situación digamos si esta es la
capacidad y si la demanda está el 90 por
ciento de capacidad entonces la gente
con la capacidad podría decir ok bueno
en vez de tratar de vender esa extra
unidad digamos esto es la demanda en vez
de vender esa unidad extra y tener que
preocuparse los materiales y trabajar
por esa unidad extra porque no solamente
subimos los precios
ok entonces la alta utilización de
capacidad conduce a un incremento de
precios
alta utilización
conduce a al incremento de precios y
esto no es un principio sofisticado de
macroeconomía es igual si estamos
dirigiendo un puesto de limonada y si de
repente comienzas a vender 95% de tu
limonada probablemente dirás bueno que
quizás es mejor si subo el precio por
otro lado la baja utilización déjenme
usar otro color
ok baja utilización
va a conducir directamente a la
reducción de precios y va de vuelta al
puesto de limonada digamos ok si solo
estoy vendiendo el 20% de la limonada
que hago quizá mi problema es que mi
limonada está muy costosa
quizás honestamente si hay muchos
puestos de limonada todo el mundo está
tratando de vender toda su capacidad
sólo para competir entre ellos tendrán
que reducir los costos de hecho voy a
incluir otra cosa que está poco
relacionada con la inflación pero una
alta utilización hace que los precios
suban y también hace que la gente
invierta más entonces ambas cosas
aumentan la capacidad pero no nos
preocupemos por eso ahora si aceptas
esto y pienso que es un argumento
razonable porque está basado en el
sentido común entonces pienso que
adoptara es el argumento de que la baja
utilización va a ser va a ser muy
difícil que generen inflación y
similarmente si tienes muy alta
utilización es difícil evitar la
inflación y para enfocar el punto de
tomado el terminal de bloomberg de
nuestra compañía y estoy copiando y
pegando estás
gráficos aquí la naranja sé que a lo
mejor no lo puedes ver bien en youtube
así que trataré de hacerlo claro en el
dibujo pero esta naranja
muestra la capacidad de utilización la
fecha de comienzo aquí creo que era 1967
ok aquí es 1969
diciembre 31 en 1970 aquí es son 1980
1990 y 2000 así que esta línea naranja
representa la capacidad de utilización
aquí está digamos el 90 por ciento ok
aquí abajo digamos está el 70 por ciento
de utilización si vemos aquí a finales
de los sesentas teníamos muy alta
utilización ajá no se podría decirse que
por la guerra de vietnam teníamos
fábricas funcionando a capacidad para
construir bombas dios sabrá que más no
luego la utilización bajó y podríamos
hablar mucho historia pero en general lo
interesante es bueno de hecho antes de
que veamos lo que pasó pensamos que es
esta línea blanca así que la línea
naranja es la utilización aquí arriba
teníamos 90 por ciento de utilización
recientemente al 2007 teníamos 80 por
ciento y muy recientemente la
utilización ha disminuido lo cual
esencialmente significa que no estamos
corriendo nuestras fábricas a tope
esta línea blanca es el crecimiento de
inflación año tras año y permítanme
hacerlo
este es el crecimiento inflacionario de
hecho déjenme dibujar una línea de cero
para poder separar inflación de
deflación
ok cero inflación está por acá
ok esta es la cero inflación
y puedes ver en esta serie de tiempo que
he hecho que nunca hemos tenido cero
inflación aunque hemos tenido periodos
de muy alta inflación verdad lo
interesante es en referencia a la
economía de los pastelillos y toda esta
noción de capacidad de utilización que
los períodos inflacionarios son siempre
anticipados siempre siempre van por lo
menos en estos datos por incrementos son
anticipados e incrementos de utilización
entonces podríamos ver esto como el
comienzo de un de un incremento
significante en los precios verdad por
ejemplo aquí nota que fue han anticipado
por incremento de la capacidad de
utilización si te fijas aquí mismo
bueno la capacidad de utilización está
comenzando a subir y otro punto
interesante es ver cuál es el umbral de
utilización que comienza a generar
inflación
digamos por aquí pues no sé ahí
estábamos en una capacidad de 1 083 84%
justo aquí
y si miramos el siguiente periodo donde
la inflación realmente comenzó a subir
digamos podemos elegir este punto no se
estaba alrededor del mismo nivel que
estaba en el anterior verdad esto era
como 82 por ciento bueno desde entonces
la inflación realmente no ha sido un
gran problema no tanto de estos son
nuestros dos principales digamos la
inflación al comienzo de los setentas y
comienzos de los ochentas y esos fueron
cuando tuvimos una extremada alta
capacidad de utilización entonces el
punto que quiero hacer aquí es que la
capacidad de utilización es realmente la
fuente de la de que los precios suban
esta línea blanca de aquí
ok ya veo no no la ves no la ves del
todo estoy fuera de la pantalla déjenme
reducir la ventana para poder mostrar
o que esto es más reciente donde vemos
que la capacidad de utilización comienza
a bajar
creo que esto es verano del 2007 y bueno
no lo ves porque está sobre escrito pero
la línea de inflación también bajó
considerablemente baja esa hasta acá
pero no hay que notar de nuevo que
aunque están muy cerca aunque están muy
cerca la utilización bajó un par de
trimestres antes que la inflación bajó
por eso siempre me pregunto por qué la
junta de gobernadores de la reserva
federal siempre hablan de distintos
indicadores de inflación cuando está la
capacidad de utilización es un buen
indicador la próxima pregunta que todos
tienen es ok bueno a ver la capacidad de
utilización conduce a la inflación
podemos aceptar eso ok pero claramente
lo que está ocurriendo ahora es una alta
impresión de dinero y la alta impresión
de dinero va a hacer que la demanda
aumente y por supuesto tendremos muy
alta capacidad de utilización y después
tendremos inflación o incluso
hiperinflación mi argumento aquí es que
normalmente ese es el caso normalmente
si tú incrementas el suministro de
dinero si subo el
ministro de dinero eso debe incrementar
la demanda pero hay un punto sutil y
casi filosófico por uno pero es
importante darse cuenta que el dinero
solo permite expresar demanda
digamos que realmente queremos comprar
un rolls-royce y justo no tenemos el
dinero si alguien me da doscientos mil
dólares en mi bolsillo entonces yo puede
expresar esa demanda de comprar el
rolls-royce ok del otro lado digamos que
yo tengo todo lo que necesito estoy
feliz con mi coche jonda a mi
apartamento de dos habitaciones y
alguien me da doscientos mil dólares
entonces aumentaron por lo menos mi
suministro de dinero va a ser eso
incrementar mi demanda por un
rolls-royce no yo tengo dinero para
expresar la demanda pero no lo haré
porque no creo que me sea necesario
podrías hacer la misma analogía en la
totalidad de la economía donde digamos
pueden puedes imaginar una isla donde no
se digamos hay 53 de nosotros 33 porque
no quiero dibujar a 5 personas
y entre nosotros usamos conchas de mar
como moneda y somos muy confiados quizás
yo soy un constructo constructor y es un
pescador y este no sé esta es una
granjera no
entonces digamos que en un año yo usan
una concha para comprar pescado luego él
usa una concha para comprar cultivos y
luego ella usa esa concha para comprar
una una casa y luego puedes ver que una
concha aunque mi suministro de dinero en
esta isla es una concha puede transitar
muchas veces en un año
entonces la velocidad en este ejemplo es
muy alta ok pero notas que mi expresión
de demanda ocurre en estas transacciones
ok
pero haré una ecuación clásica de
suministro de dinero después pero puedes
imaginar otra realidad donde por alguna
razón yo dejo de confiar de confiar
perdón en esa persona me he vuelto
cauteloso y no quiero darle mi concha
porque no estoy seguro si voy a recibir
esa concha de regreso para hacer otra
cosa entonces puedes imaginar una
realidad en donde el banco central de
nuestra isla de repente encuentra
cientos de conchas y ellos ponen las
conchas en los bolsillos de todos y así
todos estamos llenos de conchitas pero
todos nosotros hemos perdido tanta
confianza en la economía que o no
estamos seguros si otra gente va
bienes y servicios que yo no quiero usar
sus bienes y servicios entonces todos
estamos reteniendo conchas esta es una
situación en donde el suministro de
dinero podría incrementar
sustancialmente pero como nadie lo
expresa en forma de demanda entonces no
va a incrementar la utilización por eso
en la situación en la que estamos ahora
si te preguntas sobre si veremos
inflación o deflación mi argumento es
mira la capacidad de utilización ok la
gente puede apuntar al suministro de
dinero
esta es una ecuación clásica de
suministro de dinero es es dinero o
suministro de dinero por la velocidad
del dinero esto es que tan frecuente los
dólares cambian de mano digamos es igual
al precio al precio promedio de bienes
por la cantidad total de bienes y
servicios que tenemos la mayoría de la
gente se pregunta bueno si aumenta el
suministro de dinero no subirán los
precios acaso bueno eso es cierto si uno
asume que la velocidad y la cantidad son
constantes pero estamos diciendo que
siempre hay hay shocks y la gente pierde
confianza esta velocidad se puede
reducir especial
cuando hay cosas como intermediarios
financieros la gente comienza a poner su
dinero bajo el colchón de hecho
frecuentemente la gente ni considera
cosas que son que no son dinero por
ejemplo esas monedas conmemorativas que
venden en la tele esas no son
consideradas parte del suministro de
dinero de todos modos ya se me acabó el
tiempo continuaré esta discusión en el
próximo vídeo